Airlander is the world's most efficient large aircraft.
It's designed to deliver ten tons of freight, 100 passengers...
...and to deliver them to places or take them to places...
...at only 10 percent the emissions of other aircraft.
What we do with Airlander is combine some of those technologies...
...that were in airships in the past,...
...but we put that together with a lifting wing.
We used modern materials and modern technologies...
...to give us an airplane that's super efficient,...
...but still takes off and lands from the ground like other airplanes.
Different to airships, which, of course, float,...
...the experience is totally different for a passenger.
We think of Airlander as much as a fast ferry because it's big; it's spacious.
Every seat is accessible to the aisle.
You can move around.
Big windows, flying much lower; it's very gentle,...
...so none of that vibration and turbulence that we're used to in other aircraft.